hi I'm Gary Stephen the chief technology
officer at Crystal Dynamics in this
video we will be showing you how we
enhance rise of the Tomb Raider 20-year
celebration for the PlayStation 4 pro
platform this video is best viewed on a
4k device with the settings at 2160p
rise of the Tomb Raider is a beautiful
game on all platforms but with the
increased power of the PlayStation 4 pro
we were able to bring unprecedented
visuals to a console for the first time
welcome to rise of the Tomb Raider 20
years celebration PlayStation 4 pro tech
video rise of the Tomb Raider will
support three different visual modes
when played on a Playstation 4 Pro with
each focusing on a different area 4k
resolution
-
and enriched visuals there's an option
for everyone
allowing players to customize their
experience 4k resolution loaded renders
game plan stunning 4k resolution while
targeting 30 frames per second the
increased resolution offers much more
detail which benefits textures
silhouettes effects and specular
highlights players who prefer gaming
with a higher frame rate can select the
high frame rate mode which supports up
to 60 frames per second at 1080p
resolution this mode offers smoother and
more fluent animation while exploring
and even tighter control during combat
lastly there is an enriched visuals mode
which renders 1080p at 30 frames per
second and uses the extra power on both
new and existing rendering features to
improve overall image quality Hardware
tessellation greatly improves the detail
of rough surfaces of the ground rocks
and bricks silhouettes and surface
features are geometrically represented
when viewed up close
making the surfaces feel even more
tangible and real
the graphics power of the PlayStation 4
Pro allows rise of the Tomb Raider to
use anisotropic filtering across all
services so indeed from an angle the
quality of the textures in the distance
is greatly enriched additional dynamic
foliage was added even more of the plans
to trees are dynamic that the plans end
when Lara walks past the trees the wind
with the increased power available on
the PlayStation 4 Pro we were able to
enhance the geometry of objects like
buildings so they have significantly
more detail when viewed at a distance as
a result pub spaces - even larger now in
aid the players exploration
all level of detail businesses were
retuned so that objects retain higher
resolution as they recede into the
distance Lara's Hera during gameplay has
been upgraded to use the same higher
quality hair that we use and synthetics
some shadows were softened to further
improve the natural look in outdoor
environments
we improve the depth of field effect to
create a nice book hair and bright
highlights visible in the scene we're
really excited to bring new technology
to concerts advise the Tomb Raider with
PlayStation 4 pro players will be able
to pick and choose their playing
preference stunning 4k resolution smooth
high frame rate for an enriched visuals
movie the award-winning rise of the Tomb
Raider 20 year celebration includes all
previously released downloadable content
a new single-player story chapter blood
ties that can also be experienced in
PlayStation VR new co-op support and
endurance mode 5 classic Lara skins and
their thanks for watching please visit
Tomb Raider calm